now before we find a house there's three
things that you need to look for when
finding properties how many things
please now most people think that
there's millions most people get
distracted about all kinds of different
things ultimately there's three things
now the most important thing that you're
looking for in a house is you're looking
for the ROI and you want the return on
investment to be positive sometimes
people find houses they say Samuel this
is a great house Samuel they're building
the train station nearby
Samuel look how big and pretty ears send
me I could rent it to my son Samuel this
house is in Bristol and my son's moving
to Bristol University and I was about to
kill two birds with one stone listen
forget all that okay never try and kill
two birds with one stone
people say to me Samuel why don't you
use your houses for this and help the
homeless brother listen I'll help the
homeless III give a lot of money away
but when I'm doing business I'm trying
to make money and then with that money I
can then help people and by the way
making money some people think oh okay
so making money that's ruthless and then
but just make money and then you can do
good things with the money so it's like
Robin Hood you know robbing from the
rich and then give it to the poor it's
not like that you want to make a lot of
money then you're gonna have to help a
lot of people that's it that's how this
game works Albert Einstein says don't
try and be successful trying to be
valuable when you variable then the
success will follow the property
investing is a business your house is
your product you tenant is your customer
it's about finding a good product
getting a good customer having good
supply and demand and then be able to
help people and then with that money
when you help people then awesome gonna
help more people but when you're in
business you need to make sure it makes
money don't get don't let your heart
rule make your head rule I was speaking
to yesterday I was speaking to a
professional football player makes a lot
of money and he was saying to me he was
asking me for my advice because he was
saying that he gets all his family
asking him for money okay and in his
coach yeah that's what happens you make
a lot of money then you got a
distribution I said how long have you
been a professional football players at
about six years I said how long you been
making really good money in about six
years I said how long have you been
helping you
all these people and all these cousins
that have suddenly appeared he said six
years I said and and and what did you
have any property CVG are you
financially free no so what would happen
if you injured your knee and you
couldn't play football anymore well I'd
be broke are your family and cousins all
these people do they live a better life
now than they did six years ago no are
they dependent on you yes
you're not helping them you're not
helping them or it'd be much better off
if you put that money into investments
become financially free because you
can't help the poor by being poor so you
want what you want to do is you want you
want to become financially free you want
to invest well and then you can help
people and the best way to help people
is to not make them reliant on you the
best way to help people is to educate
them so return on investment when you're
looking for houses it's all about the
are our next capital appreciation
expectations what does this mean when
you buying properties you looking for
houses where the market has bottomed out
what do I mean by that if you want to
predict what's gonna happen just look at
the past of that place I'll give you a
little secret now okay after a recession
an expansion and after an expansion will
always always follow I twice as loud
recession a recession in the city is not
a bad thing it's just an inevitable
thing it's not a bad thing now most
people when they buy houses because
here's what happens here's how property
prices go up it goes expansion recession
expansion recession little expansion
little recession big expansion big
recession that's how it happens but on
average over time it goes up now what
most people do because they were
uneducated and because they go off their
feelings and feelings are not the good
way to invest
what most people do is they go oh how
spices are doing well here
Wow they've doubled in the last six
years I'm gonna buy I mean oh my
goodness I better sell before I lose any
more money and then there's our property
investing whiskey
but the reason that you're here is
because you want to be trained yes or no
so you if you want to be trained here's
what you need to do you need to find
where properties have bottomed out and
you need to be this guy
and then when properties then what do
you do here
you don't sell you refinance why do you
not sell to reasons other than they sell
a property when it stops giving you cash
flow if you sell you're gonna make a
load of profit yes because you let's say
you bought the house for a hundred grand
and now it's 200 grand you sell the
house 100 thousand pounds boom in profit
what do you have to do with that profit
that's called capital gains tax so the
capital gains covers appreciation you
gotta pay tax so that 100 grand that you
just made maybe goes down to 60 70 grand
shoot however you make a hundred grand
and instead of selling you refinance now
refinancing all that means is lending
against it so you get the hunter ground
still but you keep the house and then
with that hundred grand you have to pay
tax how much tax you pay any tax and
what do you do is I hold your end you
buy more houses that's how you can keep
building your portfolio paying zero dad
but that's capital appreciation how do
you know any capital appreciation is
gonna happen
look at what's going on in the area how
many would like it if we can find some
if I can find a property that is number
one
giving ROI of 20% or close enough and in
a capital appreciation expectant area
and there's a third one this is the real
icing on the cake and this is below
market value if you can get a house
that's below the true current market
value and it's gonna be expected to go
up in value and give you a lot of
capital appreciation meaning that you
can then remortgage pay no tax and buy
more houses and become an accidental
millionaire and you're making a return
on investment so the money that you're
putting in you're getting a 20% return
on investment let me tell you something
you don't matter where it is doesn't
matter if it's close to home it doesn't
matter what the house looks like it
doesn't matter the price of the house he
doesn't matter what the gardens like
doesn't matter if you like it doesn't
matter if you live there yourself
doesn't matter about the schools doesn't
matter about anything because if you can
take those three boxes that's what I
call the dream property
[Music]
you